[Music]
hiya girls did you see that goal last
night it was so offside v eh
ah and what about the England first 15
for the rugby I don't know is this like
your workplace according to one mad cat
management consultant chat like that is
a gateway to more laddish behavior and
bosses should be attempting to rein in
such sports banter chief executive of
the chartered Management Institute and
Frank said women feel excluded from such
conversations and they can lead to
slapping each other on the back and
talking about your conquests on the
weekend what insulting sexist trash is
this barmy boss not to wear plenty of
women both enjoy sport and enjoy talking
about it
surely this takes us back to the days of
the little lady who's left totally
nonplussed by the intricacies of the
offside rule however I was prepared to
give it a go
what about Jenna and Brad ah and that
outfit do a leaper was wearing now what
am I going to wear tonight does my bum
look big in this so the only time I'm
ever bored on this show is in the
minutes before the recording starts and
you're there and granddaddy daggers
there and the two of you start talking
about the merits or otherwise of the
previous night's football crickets rugby
whatever it is right I sit there quietly
ageing
and I'm not offended I don't feel left
out I'm just bored at my box and the
only reason I don't get up walk away is
because I'm attached to a mic and a
motor record to show however but we've
got the rock this this woman Anne Frank
I don't know what will she moves in and
the kind of women she's talking about
but every woman I know if you're bored
with the conversation in any worker pin
you get up and you walk away from it if
it's if it's sport which is what I would
do normally I'd get up and walk away and
the same way guys would get up walk away
if we were talking about periods of
makeup the idea that we need some kind
of
legislation or legal protection to
protect us from this you know it paints
us to like West some flimsy fragile
little creatures that can't manage on
the place I would have thought women
have more things to worry about in the
workplace than whether I'm talking about
the offside honestly I just don't care I
mean I love it when I live with three
men yes we know only the news of the
world was still going
I was absolutely through what happened
last night in our house with three men I
drink today actually Westham V Liverpool
yes and I had to monitor what was going
on on the what family what's that group
I'm at I'm gonna get you a pint who
wants a pie what's the school you know
where are you come back you know get
back to kickoff I love the fact that
they've got football days this is the
way that men bond another of sons knows
how they talk to their dad or to their
mates or to their brothers about
football and I say and you celebrate I
celebrate it I think actually to your
point it is rather infantilizing and yes
strange that the decision has been made
that perhaps some women wouldn't be
interested as you get to college like I
don't really particularly want to talk
about love island but sure but where do
you then what kinds of conversation man
anything my boys watch that too indeed
which kinds of conversations do you then
start saying this makes people
uncomfortable this one doesn't this one
who makes that decision and in fairness
6.1 million people tuned into love
island whereas 26 25 million tuned into
the England versus Croatian the World
Cup yeah so in terms what I want to
explore with you for me and I found this
bit actually this is where it wasn't a
funny story I found this a little bit
offensive and I'll get you in on this as
well magic but the idea that you go from
what an extraordinary goal or what a
sabre what a try to wow what a weekend I
had I had these this many conquests and
I got off with a girl from accounts and
you know I look I found that really
offensive that a bloke would go from
that to that
that's the gateway point that's the
gateway point the point I was making
yeah which a woman made fin yeah I
wouldn't say no I wouldn't say that's a
gateway I think I'd say just okay let's
put it this way
if I was in an officer and everyone was
talking about football I would feel
excluded because I know nothing about
football I basically play FIFA as a way
to pretend as if I know things about
offended I wouldn't be offended however
however if I was in an office where I
knew that one person didn't really know
much about the topic that we tended to
talk about I would try to as a decent
human being
shift the conversation towards the
topics that that person knew about but
there's no doubt though that football
has been as a tool to exclude women
Heidi Arabia's only just allowed women
in football is used is a sort of all
main male space that women are allowed
into let's just hear from Alex Scott who
was a former England not saying me this
is from Alec Scott former England
footballer and she says the abuse I've
had on social media just for having an
opinion on football has been tough to
take I had all of it for being a woman
on TV for being a woman of color on TV
that I'm ticking a box death threats at
one point I thought why am I doing this
it's being on TV talking about football
worth being threatened on social media
but then something shifted and I thought
why should I stop doing it they're not
going to win I just think this is this
is a really interesting quote from a guy
called Peter Fuchs and I think this is
very pertinent he said he's a recruit
and he says I've seen managers and staff
build a more direct bond over a shared
love of sport which has excluded those
who don't share that interest the answer
is not to ban the conversation it is to
ensure managers and staff are trained to
understand that those shared interests
should not get in the way of management
decisions of working collaboration
that's the point because men who bond
over sport you can get promotions on the
back of that you might like them better
you're a boss would you try if you heard
that they were talking ceaselessly about
cricket or [ __ ] it does it fall to
you to take action no I think I think I
think there's a deeper problem here and
this points to a kind of a culture of
increasingly policing what people say
how they say and to whom they say and I
think it's a focus on the negative
rather what would be a better option I
think is to focus on the positive
the inclusion point try and include
others in conversation try and work out
strategies to make sure people don't
feel
rather than telling people about
conversations in the Rachel we getting
it - would you ban blokes going off and
paying golf and doing deals on the golf
course I mean it's the same sort of
thing it's saying it's an exclusive area
Italy sorry it is important if you don't
have it if you do recognize that one
person is constantly socially excluded
in the workplace then you don't have a
strategy to promote inclusion by Spicer
just giving a quick nice play thing
maybe talk about some other topics you
guys even if there was a group of like
ten women who are constantly talking
about football and one guy who took no
interest in football it would still be
an exclusionary because only one left
out and everyone else is talking about
this thing that's my reduce and that's
why I started playing p4 uni but it's
still essentially something they try to
know how a strategy like that would
actually work and then you again I come
to you again and I look at you because
you'd run stuff I don't quite know how
you set it up with implement yes no
that's right so you just got up when I
say strategy I don't mean you know
things on paper I just mean in your mind
you've got I think it helps to focus on
the positive rather than negative don't
tell people what not to talk about yeah
rather trying it you know for example if
you're a boss you can organize events
for staff that makes them feel included
in other ways I don't think it's helpful
to try and police conversation and I
bring that back to the point about which
subjects are acceptable to talk about
which aren't I mean love island football
you know factory copy erection on the
assumption that a guy wouldn't be
interested another assumption that
people are making your conversations is
that I'm just aging here that's my
problem okay now there comes a point in
every relationship but when the magic
starts to fade talk turns from
suspenders to dirty socks and everything
just seems a little less exciting for
some lucky couples post wedded bliss
only ends with the pitter-patter of tiny
feet for others it doesn't last much
longer than the wedding cake but from
one man in Berman
a moment of madness following a ray with
his new bride could have led to a
lifetime in the doghouse were it not for
a certain four-legged friend here's PC
called Warhol and PD Odin to tell the
tale
well Dean what you think Blanca Perez
around on the phone with these misses
then throws his ring thinks play
Robbie's and luckily was passing boy
and you saw him two minutes to find it
back on ships within five minutes dogs
are trained to find human scent they do
Dean found two minutes time back on
patrol and a good plan the back of the
dog I was offered a few beers but
obviously turned him down
the blood was ecstatic Odin for giving
this bride and groom their happy ever
after you are our hero Hound of the week
nice that's improvement because
apparently these two guys were scrapping
around in the road when his wedding ring
cuz he had around with his Sonia
Thurmond but but then when the police
saw him he was scrapping around in the
road so that ring true how did they be
married not long not long not listened
to the newlyweds they are newlyweds
wingman of the year okay that's it for
most this week but if you want to join
the debate just search for the pledge on
Twitter we'll find us on Sky News
Facebook page and you can also listen on
the go just took up the pledge wherever
you normally listen to podcast thanks
for watching and we'll see you next time
[Music]